I saw an indie wire post that said three
ted talks every filmmaker should watch
one of which was Andrew Stanton writer
of wall-e to toy story John Carter etc
and he says goods a great TED talk the
audience wants to work for their meal
meaning they want to solve a puzzle or a
story and I hadn't really thought about
that so how do you think that you make
the audience work for their meal let's
take desires of the heart how would you
say that you worked to make the audience
kind of hang in there try to follow the
puzzle without showing them too much
that's a tricky balance you follow as a
filmmaker one of the things that I have
an issue with at the moment in most of
the mainstream films i think is that a
lot of directors and filmmakers and
screenplays are making films that end
with periods that give you this very
distinctive this is the world this is
how it is and this is the ending and all
wraps it up in a nice tiny little bow
and i think that if you want to make a
more effective film some of my most
favorite films always end in a question
mark not the period because when you
leave the audience with a question
you're doing two things one you're
trying to give them something to solve
on the journey of making the film but
also when you leave them as the credits
come up you're leaving with something to
ponder or something to think about with
something that maybe not fully resolved
the ambiguous ending if you will and
with desires of the heart that was
something i really tried hard to do
throughout the film to kind of be
leaving these little clues throughout
the way but not answering all the
questions and even when you get to the
end of the film i tried to leave it with
a question mark as well instead of the
definitive ending because I believe that
viewers are intelligent and you should
give people the opportunity to interpret
endings and interpret your film as you
progress with it if you're constantly
giving them those periods I think you're
treating your audience with disrespect
you